I thank everyone for coming I think we
should turn the speaker series into
people who really don't need an
introduction speaker series but I will
give a brief introduction regardless
this is Tom Friedman a famous writer
three Pulitzer Prizes New York time
columnist many of you all might not have
realized that that we we know each other
and and that every morning we coordinate
our outfits what are you wearing today
so we do pink today yes but but it's
it's it's a real honor to have you here
and and and where I like to start is I
mean a lot of people know you as like
the public person and and I do this
really for a lot of frankly a lot of
people who just might be watching Khan
Academy young students or whatever and
I'm always curious how a Tom Friedman
becomes the Tom Friedman I mean what
what brought you on this path um so it's
interesting I grew up in was born in
Minnesota
um I grew up in st. Louis Park a small
suburb of Minneapolis yeah I've always
thought to be a successful columnist and
whether I am or not someone else can
judge but it's really important to be
from somewhere so it's really important
to be grounded in in a in a worldview
that you take around the world and you
measure against other things you see and
so the thing you have to understand
about my column is I'm always looking
for Minnesota yeah so what does that
mean it means I grew up in Minnesota at
a particular time when politics really
sort of worked so I graduated from high
school in 1971 and that was the year
that Walt that our sorry our governor
sandy has last name now Anderson was on
the cover of Time magazine holding up a
walleye under the a walleye fish a
walleye walleye fish yeah it's a
Minnesota fish under the headline
Minnesota the state that works so I grew
up in a totally liberal district and my
whole life my congressmen were too
liberal Republicans not Democrats my
Senators growing up or Walter Mondale
Eugene McCarthy and Hubert Humphrey Wow
the companies I grew up with were a
Dayton Hudson Target Honeywell 3m who
thought it was part of their
responsibility
reduce corporate social responsibility
to build the symphony to fund education
programs so it gave me I now only
realize in retrospect a very powerful
sense of that politics is something that
can work that communities can come
together and so when I later yo went to
the Middle East or Beirut or whatever I
carried that with me and a lot of what I
saw was I wish I saw communities falling
apart somebody else may have said
something else so my life changed in in
10th grade I had a great teacher
um and her name was Hattie Steinberg and
she taught journalism in room 313 at st.
Louis Park High School and her class is
still the only journalism course I've
ever taken
not because I'm that good but because
she was that good it's the only one I
ever needed and she really inspired me
to want to be a journalist and and and a
writer and in that same year my parents
took me to Israel on a trip to visit my
sister is going to school there I had
never been out of the state of Minnesota
I was 15 except for a few brief forays
into Wisconsin and I had never been on
an airplane and so that was my first
trip I came to the Middle East came to
Israel and I was kind of blown away so I
actually lived on a kibbutz all three
summers of high school I got totally
fascinated with the Middle East drop
everything and was just totally absorbed
with journalism and the Middle East and
I then went to college I started taking
Arabic as a freshman I eventually did a
semester at the Hebrew University in
Jerusalem a semester at American verse
in Cairo and I graduated in in 1975 from
Brandeis ultimately and in Middle East
Studies and I had a Marshall scholarship
to study Arabic in Middle East history
ultimately in England I did my first
year at the School of Oriental and
African Studies in I went to Oxford and
sort of had a classic British Arabist
education at st. Anthony's but while I
was in London I then I met my then
girlfriend now wife and bucksmom and who
was a Stanford grad would graduated a
year early and kind of she said told her
dad you owe me a year at college so she
decided to go LSE for a year and we met
through mutual friends in London and my
real journalism career started because
this was 1975 and we were walking down
the street in London and you know the
Evening Standard newsstand they always
have that blaring headline you
no Brad - Jen were finished by the
evening paper and we're walking down the
street in London and I saw the headline
on the Evening Standard and it said
Carter to Jews : if elected I promise to
fire dr. K and I I stopped and looked at
that and I said to my then girlfriend
now wife isn't that interesting this guy
is running for president jimmy carter
he's trying to win jewish folks by
promising to fire henry kissinger the
first every jewish Secretary of State so
how could that be and that sort how my
mind works and I have no idea what
possessed me but I went back to my dorm
and I wrote a column about it and I my
then girlfriend now wife really liked it
and she is from Des Moines Iowa she took
it home on a spring or winter break I
don't remember now and gave it to a
family friend named Gilbert cranber--
who is the editorial page editor of the
DesMoines edge astir and wonderful
Midwest paper at that time and he liked
it and he printed it on their op-ed page
half the op-ed page under an auth
cartoon and they have cartoon oh yeah a
cartoonist Oh under an Oscar tune wrong
time frame yeah and and they paid me $50
Wow and I thought that was the coolest
thing in the whole I was walking down
the street I had an opinion I went and
wrote it I gave it to someone and they
paid me 50 people pay for this and I
just thought I was hooked ever after so
during my time at Oxford I wrote op-ed
columns about the Middle East for the
Minneapolis Star entry of you and my
hometown paper where else into the
auditory page editor and for my wife's
then-girlfriend wife's hometown paper so
I graduated from Oxford in 78 and I had
a wonderful time there I studied with
Albert irani a great Erebus story and a
wonderful man and so I went to apply for
a job and I decided I was apply could
friend of mine I applied at ap once in
London so I applied for a job at The
Associated Press and United Press
International in London and the AP said
you you've you've never covered a fire
you've never covered a city hall meeting
but I had a dozen
from the Middle East and UPI kind of be
Avis and ap being hurt said look the
kids never covered a fire but if he
could do this we could probably teach
them that and there's just been a
revolution in Iran and they think they
use the same kind of letters as a bunch
of squiggles and if he knew the Arabic
stuff maybe we could teach him to do
that and so they hired me for $200 a
week on Fleet Street and I worked there
for almost a year when the number two
man and the Beirut Bureau of UPI got
shot in the ear by a man robbing a
jewelry store on Hamra Street and he
called the headquarters and said I want
to get out of here I do not want to pass
go I do not want to collect $200 they
route and Beirut started a lot in the
even a year by man robbing a jewelry
store at a jewelry store and so they UPI
came to me and said do you want to go to
Beirut you are like 25 25 25 years old
and um I've never been to Beirut I've
been to Egypt never been to Beirut so I
turned to my then wise civil war civil
war just started 75 so this was now it's
well into its third year this was 79
fourth year actually and we just said
this is our moment and gotta go and
you're right so and she she she signed
up um and so we went off to Beirut and
my first night there at the Commodore
hotel I I heard a gunshot fired and that
was the first time I'd ever heard a
gunshot in my life and um you did hear a
lot of those in Salus Park and so we're
in Beirut for two years Civil War had a
very profound experience a searing
experience on me because what is and I
don't mean this in a voyeuristic way but
when you're in one of those situations
you see how molecules behave at very
high temperatures so what you see is
what people are capable of for both good
and ill for good and evil in a way
you'll never see in any normal
environment so the whole color spectrum
goes out to here and you learn an
enormous amount about people and about
yourself so I did that for two years and
then the New York Times hired me went
back to New York for about 11 months as
their correspondent I saw as a business
correspondent covering oil and then they
sent me back to Beirut in
April 1982 and I realized that date
doesn't mean anything to anyone in this
room weren't born then but Israel
invaded Lebanon six weeks later and the
Lebanon story became the biggest story
in the world and so I covered the
Israeli invasion the Marines come in the
Marines going the US Embassy bombing
Sabra and Shatila the massacres all the
journalists I covered the Hama massacre
in Syria which was the precursor to
what's going on now and maybe the most
important experience of that because
we're just at the 20th anniversary sorry
30th anniversary of the US Embassy
bombing and it's quite important and
it's doubly important for what I'll
share with you so and on I think it was
April 18th you can check the date 1983 I
was sitting in my apartment in Beirut in
West Beirut and I had a little
transistor radio on my desk that was
something that was used back then in the
Dark Ages to actually listen to the BBC
that's how I got my news and and there
was a there was a blast so powerful that
it actually knocked the radio off my
desk like a earthquake almost and so I
did what journalists do back there and I
just ran down to the street and to do
two things one is Israeli set off a lot
of sonic booms by supersonic jets over
Beirut so a sonic boom sounds a lot like
a car bomb or anything you don't know
that and so the first thing you listened
for our sirens it's a sonic boom you
won't hear sirens if it's not if your
sirens it's bad and I quickly saw a
mushroom cloud curling up in the
distance and a big one and so I just ran
toward it and that's what we do you know
I mean so and I got closer and closer
and said on it could couldn't be it
could not could and I sort of rounded
the turn at the American University in
Beirut and there was the US Embassy
which I used to live across the street
from cut in half like a doll's house
bodies hanging out you know papers desks
a smoldering smoking ruin
and staggering around um was a young
political officer named Ryan Crocker who
actually spoke to you today because Ryan
later became ambassador to Beirut to
Syria to Afghanistan in Iraq and I don't
remember it's him or someone else but I
said what happened and they said a man
drove a truck you remember US Embassy in
those days had no perimeter wow you just
walked up to the front door right a man
drove a truck through the driveway up
the front stairs into the lobby and blew
it up and I'll never forget what I said
you mean he blew himself you mean he
committed suicide right that was unheard
of that was I mean I I literally I could
not get my mind around it and that was
the beginning that was the first one and
that's really where the phenomena
started so anyways a did two more years
in Beirut for the New York Times it was
a remarkable remarkable in the sense of
the did you see the human drama that
played I have about eight million brain
from but I mean especially when you hear
about war correspondents people who are
in this war zones I mean did you I mean
your and your wife's there with you yeah
did you fear for your life I mean you
could go back to wherever New York I
mean the Apple is right ball of America
wasn't built then so there were times
that I came to Beirut in April 1982 the
war started in June and unfortunately in
the first week of the war a massive
number of refugees came up from the
south mostly Palestinian my driver in
Beirut was a Palestinian and he'd worked
for the time since the 50s actually as a
driver for Kim Philby I mean
Mohammed had seen like it all and we he
began to fear for my safety because
refugees were taking over apartments
that any a vacant apartment and this was
summer so a lot of Beirut ease had gone
to you know other people just a lot
and breaking an empty apartment move
India and so he chose he decided to move
his wife and two daughters into my
apartment and moved me into the hotel he
thought it would be much safer for me
and tragically two groups of refugees
got in a fight over my building and the
one that lost blew it up and so the
building was completely destroyed and
unfortunately my driver's wife and two
daughters were killed in my apartment
and that was in the first week of the
war and so you know that was obviously I
could have been there my wife hadn't
come over yet you know I really said you
know people always ask you that and I
honestly don't think about I remember
once being out the interview are fought
when his Raiders bombed the neighborhood
and I just remember that when a big
concussion bomb hits how it sucked all
the oxygen out of the air
I was once walking around Beirut Airport
with the Marines when a ricochet came
over our heads and when a ricochet
caused the ricochet slows down a bullet
you can actually hear it turning when he
gets closer to you yeah so I remember
those kind of things but you know most
the time I tried to be prudent people
say Joe a bulletproof vest and my motto
is if you need a bulletproof vest you're
somewhere you shouldn't be because yeah
there's no sense in getting yourself
killed so I tried to be as prudent as I
could I still did some crazy-ass things
but I used to walk home at night after
work at 11:00 which I still can't
believe and I wrote about this I wrote a
book called to me about they were to
Jerusalem and dump there was a time
where I was walking home at night with
my wife as a teenager I really it's good
yeah after a movie and we were walking
down the streets of Beirut and a man
jumped out a window on with a pistol his
hand and literally landed like right in
front of us and I just say Beirut was so
dangerous at night you could walk home
because even the criminals were afraid
to be on but he looked at us and we
looked at him yeah and he just like Bob
as a bat man you know jumped out but but
basically we tried to be prudent we
obviously saw some many tragic scenes I
as a that kid from Saint Louis Park
never had to help dig his driver's wife
and two daughters out of the rubble of
an apartment so it was a searing
experience for me
and um you hold a lot of stuff in
because I was there for the New York
Times is my first assignment for The
Times the city was under seeds they
couldn't get more reporters in so they
were stuck with me and um but at the end
of the summer I might deal with The
Times was that I'm gonna stay here I was
in the south when Israel invaded and I'm
gonna stay here till the PLO leaves so
that was the negotiation the PLO is
gonna leave you know what not and
because I wanted you know in your career
at the New York Times if you write one
sixth column headline story for the New
York Times that's a big deal right I
probably had eight that summer you know
these were and I wanted to have Israel
invades and war ends you know and I just
you know I was gonna stick it out so um
the day finally came at the PIO left and
I always give this as a lesson to young
journalists um Business Saturday I went
down to the port to watch them go and
trucks get on these boats to Greece and
Tunisia and whatnot and I actually was
with Peter Jennings the late Peter
Jennings from ABC and I remember he was
standing there and a palestine's are all
shooting the GAO in the air and um we
were covered in shell cases I just one
of my searing memories but it was an
amazing scene and had been there all
summer and it's just the culmination of
the whole thing and um I went back to
the Reuters bureau where so where I
worked and just one of noisy old-time
newsrooms which I love by the way those
days um
you worked on something he was called a
typewriter okay and so I worked on an
Adler I so proud I had a German
typewriter
actually got blown up but um I got
another one and I'm in the Reuters
bureau working on my typewriter the way
you wrote stories back then the way you
wrote your news story you had to write
it's three paragraphs at a time hand it
to a telex operator they punched it into
telex tape and then it was telex to the
New York Times came out as telex tape
and they fed it into a computer and that
then that was edited that's how it all
work try writing a story three
paragraphs at a time yeah so you have to
write the whole thing through because
you gotta know where you're going then
right is through again and then you kind
of write it through and hand it in so I
I'm it's but Saturdays by three o'clock
I'm doing this I'm writing this my last
is a culmination of the
all summer and all the communications
from Beirut to the west of the world
went down somebody basically either
unplugged the PTT because they only
through one PTT line post telephone and
telegraph and no cell phones then no
nothing so the entire communications
between Beirut and the rest of the world
were cut down
I still today have the telex tape in a
shoe box of my last story from Lebanon I
stayed by the telex all night to see if
it would come on it never did and that
Sunday morning under six column headline
said Palestinians evacuate Beirut
Associated Press and well I always tell
young journalists about that is that
it's really my view of life which is
that it's all about the journey not
about the destination I love the movie
Moneyball because you just got to enjoy
the show and sometimes you don't have
the headline you don't have the thing
but I don't mean enjoy a war but you're
saying you know they've just got a real
excuse got it limit yeah it's got to be
satisfied by the experience because
sometimes that the PTT goes down you
know and you never had experience like
that gentleman who got his ear shot
we're just like oh no you know I never
you know you do get I I'm not I'm not
some super guy I mean I just you do get
hardened to it though you try to be
prudent I mean Beirut to Jerusalem I
talked about a scene where I was with a
colleague who they did get into to
Beirut at one point and he was very
jittery and nervous about the whole
thing and at one point I was working on
my story on deadlines and we're at the
Reuters Bureau and there is a man
shooting at another person in the park
across the street and he came over to me
said did you see that guy that had the
gun in his gut he was shooting like this
and I just looked up I said bill was he
shooting at you because if he wasn't
shooting at you I am on deadline okay
and obviously was not like summit but
you're just really focused about what
you do you know and and I tried I was
not people did much crazier things in me
I just not didn't
you know I tried to take care of myself
at obviously you you're in a dangerous
situation Beirut you're in a dangerous
situation but you know I'll tell you Sal
the people I went through that with will
I go back to Lebanon pretty much once a
year still because they are among my
closest and dearest friends because we
were all on the Titanic together you
know and the friends I have who I went
through Beirut with are like no friends
I have a there's another story from
Beirut to Jerusalem that I love to tell
because we had a our local reporter
there New York Times a guy named Exxon
he has a brilliant Palestinian reporter
and a real teacher of mine and he tells
the story in the book because Israel's
were bombing they would all the time
then and one point they were in their
living room you know just waiting for
the bombing to end and with a candle
going on and a mouse appeared and it was
like he and his wife were up on the
couch
I mean like fear you can be afraid of
funny things yeah I mean like the
bombing has come they can be obliterated
anymore but that mouse the daylights
idea and so you you get just really
funny things like you you you don't have
experiences like that anywhere else we
you learn so much about human nature and
so I was there for over the course of
five years I was there that probably
four full years so they went back for
the New York Times and the time said hey
do you want to go to Jerusalem so the
New York Times had never had a Jewish
reporter in Israel it was a rule of the
paper and they they tried to change that
rule my predecessor David shipler but
they discovered after they appointed him
that he just looked Jewish but he wasn't
actually Jewish okay
and so they didn't make that mistake
with me and and they said you've already
done Barry would not do Jerusalem and no
one ever done that before so I thought
that'd be kind of interesting so I did
that for five years and that was um a
very different experience the boundaries
you know were much narrower you know the
color spectrums you did you didn't have
and um I did that and then I took a year
off I wrote from Beirut to Jerusalem
then I when I got back to Washington
they said whoever becomes the next
president you will be the chief
diplomatic correspondent so I they
turned out to be George Bush the elder
he named Jim Baker Secretary of State
and so after my year off writing this
book
I became the chief diplomatic
correspondent and traveling like
Secretary of State yourself no actually
I not not only should I know it's not
false modesty in the least I didn't know
anything about anything other than
Middle East and so I got a great
education traveling with Baker first
nine months was really boring and I'm
thinking I gave up covering a drama to
covering a policy and I gave up carving
a Streep to covering a hall like what
did you do and and then this uh this
wall and Bay in Berlin came down and and
suddenly I found myself traveling seven
hundred fifty thousand miles with Baker
with a front row seat to the end of the
Cold War you're like in the plane they
play they say he takes ten reporters
with him and it was just an amazing
front row seat to the end of the Cold
War so I felt like I was really lucky
twice because in this business of you're
in the right place at the right time one
time like you're lucky and I thought
this was really lucky so I did that for
four years great education then I just
very quickly I was a chief White House
correspondent for the first year of Bill
Clinton and that was mr. Toad's Wild
Ride I have to tell you mr. Toad's Wild
Ride that was such a crazy-ass
experience thing I don't know what White
House was just they were fun and he was
fun and and it was I thank God it was
the end of the Cold War so it wasn't a
serious time so uh uh nobody got hurt
you know and that's the stuff that that
you saw that's right it was yeah but I
did that for a year and covering the
White House it's an experience every
journalist should have because it's a
very interesting experience but none
dare call it journalism you know I said
across between babysitting and
stenography you know because you uh
you're there but you know you got to go
everywhere with your baby see the press
so you also know where you go every go
yeah but you take turns flying an Air
Force one because it's a pool you know
so so I thought I did it for a year but
like I got the point after year and said
I don't really want to do this because
one of these were covering the White
House and the State Department is back
in those days again the prehistoric days
the Washington Post and New York Times
exchanged front pages at 10:30 every
evening so we saw what they had
and they saw what we had really and it
was a little restraint of your ba
obvious trade people don't realize and
if you're sitting at home when you're
covering the White House or the State
Department there's just one thing you
don't want a phone call at 10:35 okay
cuz when the phone rings at 10:35 you
are only bad things they're gonna happen
well that okay the Washington Post in
law or no their editor says the
Washington Post has a front-page story
that Jim Baker is about to announce this
and you have to start to match it at
10:35 at night you haven't lived till
you've called a senior administration
official at home at 10:35 at night okay
to match a Washington Post story and so
not only are you up till midnight
matching their story but you know when
you come into the office the next
morning everyone knows they've got the
lead story that you missed okay so
anyways that's just part of prehistoric
age you know basically no Twitter then
they would coordinate not to be
embarrassed exactly she would give each
other a chance to match each other's
story but with the codicil that said as
reported in the Washington Post first
you know so right you had to kind of eat
that crow you know hoping for you yeah
before you matched it and so then I they
transferred me to be the chief economics
correspondent the Treasury Department
and this was sort of this no early 90s
netscape's just been invented this thing
called the Internet I remember when Bill
Clinton was president like the president
no nted email okay
there was no one had heard email so um
and this thing called goo-goo-goo
globalization was a warning and so I was
at the Treasury Department just as we
were kind of shifting from general
Powell to General Electric you know in
terms of our our kind of concerns and
the knack third words yeah I don't know
where it comes from it's a they tell me
that so it's a and so I did that for
three years and then they made me the
Foreign Affairs columnist and I've been
doing that ever since and then I came
here yesterday so he came yesterday and
I think this is destiny because you talk
about these life moments one discovering
the op-ed how you could communicate
and all of these other experiences
there's this form factor called the
YouTube video yes which I think some
organizations could get you to make in
some videos absolutely I know I should
do that and I thought of doing a MOOC
yes it's funny so I um
my my youngest daughter went to Williams
College and Williams head is on the four
one four system and this is relevant now
for Khan Academy I think which is that
so the one is a winter term which kind
of fun so you take winemaking trip to
Moscow but it's a freshman you have to
do yes on campus so um in a shameless
effort to be near my daughter I agreed I
had a friend there was teaching a course
on teaching actually I agreed to teach a
course on how to write a column and and
it was it was really fun
for for one reason I realized that um
like I've learned about globalization
and written about I've learned about the
Middle East I've written about it but I
know how to write a column and it was
really fun to write about something you
know really deeply and to teach it right
so the way the course was constructed I
created a little book for the class and
you had to because I did taught it with
a friend of mine who is a educator so
you I did you got to teach a lesson yeah
okay
on Tuesday and then you had to write a
column off that lesson on Thursday and I
would come to class and they would
emailed their columns ahead of time and
then I would deconstruct them in front
of them say you know the 18th graph is
really the lead the lead is really the
kicker you know I showed them I kind of
take it apart for them so um what I did
though was I created a six of seven
chapter book I guess on how to write a
column and I just did this Mumia graphed
you know but because my view is that
there's actually just six kind of
columns and if you write a column that
gets any one of these six reactions you
have a column right so and then I give
examples of all six and the last chapter
was Tom Friedman is a big fat idiot
right wing pinko left wing
bottom-dwelling slug
I took a days or weeks blogs about me
and I put them all in one chapter you
know about what a flaming jerk I am
um and just explain to people at being a
columnist is not a friend growth
industry and that you want my life are
you ready for Chapter seven
okay because you've got to be ready for
chapter 7 because
I lived with that Greek chorus everyday
okay so so the six kind of columns are
if so if you were to calm it proves one
of these six reactions you got to calm
the first is sown reads it and says I
didn't know that
that's a column yeah you tell people
something I didn't know from reporting
you know you report something Wow I
didn't know that second is I never
looked at it that way you give people a
new perspective yeah I'm sorry I never
looked at that one third your favorite
you live for this happens half a dozen
times a year if you're lucky you said
exactly what I felt but I didn't know
how to say god bless you thank you so
much
the fourth is I want to kill you dead
you and all your offspring okay because
your column is defined as much by people
who are against it will actually write
that to you oh yeah that's that's
nothing I mean that's the nice stuff
okay I'd like to dance on Your Grave you
know other people have written that oh
oh you get a you get everything but you
really need to you know if you don't
take chances if you don't you know you
see you gotta you gotta better take
people on and be taken off um v very
hard do not try this trick at home kids
you made me laugh you made me cry very
hard to do when you do it well oh wow it
really works when you do it badly
bad humor or bad sort of sentimentality
is cringe-inducing so don't try that one
unless you're really gonna pull it off
and less is what I simply call you
challenged me and that is when a
columnist challenges his own readers
which I believe in doing I do a lot of
that and and um so to me if you write
and I give examples of all six so if you
write one of those kind of six columns
you got a column and you target one or
just you just go around and think about
what you want to write you write it and
then you and then you say oh that's
category three with a little bit of four
no I'm not thinking about it you know I
mean I guys I know so my head
intuitively I know I know what it is so
right now I've got actually three
columns wrestling in my head shooting me
before I came here I checked on
ambassador Ryan Crocker and a plane in
LaGuardia after I talked to you um
because I had a thought about Syria that
was triggered by something
he wrote in The Washington Post says
excuse me this morning I'm thinking
about some of the things you said
because it melds well with a McKinsey
study that somebody sent me yesterday
and um I did a column with a bunch of
healthcare innovators last week at HHS I
did research for it
so I got that in my head some time
tomorrow I'll make a commitment for
Sunday yeah but right now all three are
wrestling and I'm carrying all three
around in my head to be a columnist you
have to
I see columns everywhere like I do it's
Nev an hour here and I could easily get
a column or two out of this you know and
if I didn't you'd kind of die like
because I do this place a week it's like
what am I gonna write for Wednesday's I
have no idea what I'm ready right I
really don't have any idea
all I know is I've got a four-hour plane
fright on Friday and I will write
whatever I like today on that four hour
plane ride okay I will make a commitment
then but so I never worry about the
ideas it's more which one to choose all
the ideas I have you know right so
that's so we will try to convince you to
get your course on Khan Academy yeah I
would love to I've really no I really
thought about doing a MOOC you know or
you know something for you guys because
it would be your great-grandchildren
will learn to write a column it's um
it's uh would be it would be a great
honor so and and and and what's I mean
throughout all of this I mean once again
I mean a million a million different
things I mean just going from the first
question of how you got started
I mean what's interesting about it is
you just started doing your career and
that's what let it's nowhere in that did
someone look at your resume and say no
all I all well they did they saw but I
went to Oxford I study you know an old
oppressor so that was that was a door
opener yeah but what really got me in
was I wrote I had a dozen columns to
show right so whatever young journalist
come to me said I want to do what you do
you know they said what do I need to do
what you do and well I said well you
know the first thing you need is it
you'd be able to type fast I can type
take good notes you need to know English
you know obviously good for our English
and try goods gram punctuate comma goes
there you know good to know some
economics politics history all those
things science environment but there's
actually just one thing you need to be a
good journalist I believe you have to
like people all right
you have to really enjoy sitting with
them and listening to the crazy things
they say and do and the incredible music
of their lives and if you cannot hear
the music you'll never be able to play
the music and I really do like people I
love interviewing them I interview them
wherever I go and and so I'm struck at
how many journalists hate people and and
I've known or several of them but I
really do like people and I enjoy
hearing the music of their life I have
an unnamed friend who was in residency
for surgical residency and he really
brilliant guy and he got some negative
feedback from one of the senior
residents and the feedback was you know
it really just doesn't look like you
care about the patients and he was
really taking that to heart
yeah then I asked him well do you care
he's like no yeah I mean I was in I was
in San Francisco yesterday and I went to
Starbucks because I needed some free
wireless because I my wireless was out
so I just was going in there and women a
guy came by said we have to buy you
coffee you're big fans yada yada and so
a court mainly said well what do you do
what do you know you're in big data
analysis fascinating give me your card
by 4:30 I met with them again I bought
them a drink and interviewed them so
there's one good thing about notoriety
of people throw [ __ ] at you true that's
you know I want to dance on it that's
right but on dancing your grave but a
lot of other people want to come up and
tell you about their lives and what they
do and they are just I cannot tell you
so how many columns stories and ideas
I've gotten from people who just come up
to me on the street in an airport in a
Starbucks and and tell you things about
about their lives so it's I'm really
open to that I'm still tickled when
someone comes up to me and and says
something god I think that's pretty
serious if someone stops you and says I
want to tell you how I feel about what
you're doing you know I mean and so you
invite that I mean I realize I welcome
Tom Friedman in an airport yeah people
do it'll come up and say you know I
agree about 90% of what you write and I
say hey that's like a perfect number for
me because it means you're always going
to check yeah um I def for a columnist
is if people say I know what he or she
is gonna write why should I read it
like I don't know what I'm gonna write
half the time because my combs very
non-ideological
and very reporting centric because I'm
still a reporter I believe the best
columnist SAR are always reporters and I
think it's actually true in every
profession because I always say I've it
colleagues to say that I want to do it
you'd only do analysis now yeah
to which I say your analysis must not be
very good because all my analysis grows
out of my reporting it's only when
you're working with the clay that you
see the patterns you feel the texture
and that's where the column comes from
and you find it difficult to kind of
maintain ground you know you put it you
say you put an op-ed and you get a bunch
of people on a message board just saying
oh you're this that you're this that
does that affect you does it maybe I am
wrong maybe I do need a little more so
it's a really complicated thing I'm not
on Twitter and on Facebook because I
just be overwhelmed so the
signal-to-noise ratio now is the noise
is so high that you you can no human
being you know people tell you I've got
a thick skin doesn't bother me I've
never met that person so anytime people
are in large numbers saying bad things
about you you you by the way many people
say the opposite but I don't so not
exaggerated but here's what I find kind
of about the comments section of the
times because we have comments under a
column so today they're made four
hundred comments you know and you always
have to be careful because the times
online which are people comment has a
little bit of a left bias who reads the
New York Times then who reads it online
you know it's going to be a younger more
left to center audience so you got to be
aware of that for starters and but you
know very often I confess I'd go to the
closet I put on my wetsuit
I fixed the helmet to my head you know
and I dive into the to the to the
comments because let's say you find a
lot they're predictable you're this
you're that they're nasty their personal
or whatever but I'll tell you so
invariably when I do it I come across
one two or three that are brilliant yeah
yeah just
and I literally cut and pasted them in
my notebook if I got to remember this
this is brilliant and that's the beauty
of a crowdsourcing so you just it comes
with the it just comes with the
territory you know you you're by the way
you're out
they're dishing it out you gotta be able
to take it so I'm a big believer in that
so you don't seem I'm not in the
internet wars like you'll never see me
you know fighting be you know without
because my attitude is um I got my say
you got your say and I'm not gonna prove
you're right you're gonna you know ten
years ago I wrote the world is flat so
since then people have written books you
know the world is not flat there's a
library they serve the Lord the spiky
lumpy junk you know and and people I
said I do what did you what did you say
about that book and I had to everybody
and this is an arrogant look I'm either
gonna be right around but we're not
gonna know for 10 years okay so come to
me in 10 years and and I'd say ten years
later yeah I got one big thing wrong it
is so much flatter than I thought right
and this place is surfing on that you
know what happened you know so so I
actually I mean you you were just saying
right before we chatting about this I
mean your most recent op-ed piece you
know Oh tell us about it cuz I think
that just start to connect with with
what we're trying to do here yeah well I
think the the what would really can I
start at just one 10,000 foot layer
higher you know which is um because I
really like to think of what I do is a
being a plumber that I'm always into
where the plumbing is so I spend a lot
of time in Silicon Valley and always
have because I'm very into where the
technology is going what its enabling
what is empowering what it's not and so
that's really what what what produced
the world is flat so I mean may I just
tell that story just for a second
because it's it's it's relevant um
so after 9/11 I spent three years in the
in the air Muslim world trying to stand
the roots of 9/11 and I wrote from
Beirut to Jerusalem then 10 years later
I wrote one of the first big books about
globalization is called the Lexus in the
olive tree okay that came out of late
90s and then I put that subject down
after 9/11 and really focused on trying
to stay on the roots of 9/11 I also
started doing documentaries and for the
Discovery Channel so Discovery Channel
in new york times created a partnership
i did a documentary after 9/11 called
the roots of 9/11 which i very proud of
and um I did one then on the wall is
really built in the West Bank and in
February 2004 we were sitting around
with our discovery team what should we
do our next documentary on and Kerry was
running against
Bush for for president and at the time
my idea was let's do a documentary about
why everybody hates America thought you
know that was a hot subject Bush was
president running for re-election why is
everybody hate us and so how should we
do that well I had this crazy idea we
should go to outsourcing centers all
over the world and interview young
people who spend their days
imitating Americans on what they think
of America I thought it'd make a
fascinating double-berry yeah you know
shall by day John by night you know Juan
by day joe by night and and so we
literally were budgeting that
documentary where do we go about Amala
Mexico City Philippines Bangalore and in
the middle of that budget debate John
Kerry came out with his blast against
Benedict Arnold CEOs who engage in
outsourcing because we just had the y2k
thing outsourced he was just becoming a
big issue so I came to The Times I said
timeout why don't we do a documentary
just called the other side of
outsourcing explain this phenomena to
people and I know none danila Connie had
emphasis and I could go to Bangalore
like that I just go ahead yeah um that
was the days when people had money and
so and so we went to Bangalore and we
spent two weeks there and I had just
come off really three years covering
9/11 and I'd read this book on
globalization late 1990s and I spent two
weeks in Bangalore and I realized I just
kept walking around saying I don't
understand the platform that's allowing
this I saw people I met people ready to
to trace my lost luggage on Delta
Airlines from Bangalore read my x-rays
from Bangalore do my taxes from
Bangalore now this all seems now normal
but back then it was like mind-blowing
so the last interview was with Nandan
Nilekani the CEO of emphasis on the yes
our Microsoft of India and he had been
out of the country there was two weeks
and he just come back I went to his
office at Electronic City and emphasis
to see and we sat on the couch outside
his office I had my laptop on my lap and
um at one point he said Tom I got to
tell you the global economic playing
field is being leveled and you Americans
are not ready oh I wrote that down in my
little life the global economic playing
field be left
carefully you and Mary it's really did
you Americans are not ready and I just
really blew my mind yeah I mean it's
sort of it connected a lot of things so
I got done with the interview I got back
of my Jeep to go back to my hotel and
it's about an hour drive from Electronic
City back to Bangalore and I'm thinking
now the whole time what non dad said the
global economic playing field is being
leveled wow he's really saying the
global economic playing field being
flattened wow I think he just told me
the world is flat yeah
and so I wrote that in my notebook yeah
the world is flat I got back to my hotel
room I literally ran up to my room and I
called my wife in Bethesda and said
honey I'm gonna write a book called the
world is flat she now says she thought
that was a brilliant idea that is not
exactly how I recall the conversation
okay okay my wife okay but but I I did
immediately came I got so excited about
it was nan Dunn's 50th birthday party I
never forget this and I was going back
to his house for dinner he had a Simon
and Garfunkel duo imitation duo he was
so excited about the idea he'd always
bangalore technique it was he Simon or
Garfunkle he was using no no no just an
imitation duo up that pass um and but he
was so excited about it he wanted me to
I thought was I literally had sketched
out on the back of an envelope kind of
the just rough crude outline of a book
and he wanted me to present it at his
birthday party to his bungalow
he was so excited about it but I got
home I called The Times I said I have to
go and leave immediately my software is
out of date I'm a basic engineer and
it's a java world and if you don't give
me a leave immediately I'm gonna write
something really stupid in the New York
Times because my software is a great way
to get a leave so my software was out of
date yeah and so they basically did they
said go you know as soon as you can't
say I want to leave in in July and that
July I went I was invited to Allen
conference in Sun Valley they've invited
me a bunch and I I just never could work
it out to go but and so then I had it
really on the back of an envelope but it
was more fleshed out and they asked me
to make a presentation Bill Gates was in
the audience and he heard it and he came
up afterwards he had taken all these
notes bill and you said that was
that was really interesting and I said
yeah no talking to me I told you
something about you know I didn't know
and he said oh no I knew all of that I
just never put it together oh he's like
a class-four yeah just like you said
yeah he said I never you know connected
all those things he said you're 90%
there and I'm gonna help you with the
last 10% interesting because that
mentoring absolutely here as well but I
mean that's was it the outsourcing craze
people were scared everything's gonna go
to India and China and it seems like
we're kind of that post fear right now
and it's true a lot of stuff is still
going to that part of the world but if
you look at the u.s. software engineer
salaries continue to go through the roof
yeah you mean here you you have more and
more innovation is actually being
focused in 20 miles around here we have
a great American cut you know Tesla now
I mean yeah how do we compare these two
things the this this notion between the
u.s. is losing his edge everything's
being outsourced and it looks like more
innovation is being focused in the u.s.
now so let's go to what happened between
2004 and today yeah because I think
that's the story that between 2004 and
today something big happened call it
flat world 2.0 I called the great
inflection but there was a merger of
globalization in the IT revolution they
kind of merged in a way that more IT
drove more globalization more
globalization drove the expansion of RIT
and they merged and so something really
big happened so in my view we went from
a connected world to a hyper-connected
world and I believe it's changing
everything and Khan Academy is now on
that platform so you know the story I
tell my son bite is that when I wrote
the world is flat so when I wrote my
last book which is about America which
in 2011 the first thing I did was go
back and get the first edition of the
world is flat off my bookshelf yeah just
to remind myself what I read and I took
it off the shelf I opened up to the
index looked under ABCDE
if a facebook wasn't in it hmm so when I
was running around the world saying the
world's flat we're all connected yeah
Facebook didn't exist
Twitter was still a sound the cloud was
still in the sky 4G was a parking place
LinkedIn was a prison and applications
went to college big data was a rap star
and Skype was a typo okay I mean all of
that happened after I wrote the world
yeah you know so what does that tell you
yeah it tells you we've gone from a
connected world to a hyper-connected
world so what are the features of that
well the features of that is that more
people now can compete connect
collaborate and invent with more other
people yeah in more different ways from
more different places for less money
than ever before right and it reached a
difference of degree so that's a
difference of kind that allows for Khan
Academy yeah that for basically zero
marginal costs you can now offer the
greatest educational lessons to anyone
you know in the world with a web enabled
cell phone or Internet enabled computer
well what's your sense of why I mean
it's like the talent you know the
offshoring fear was that all the
software engineering jobs are gonna go
to India what's your sense of why we see
it we actually saw the opposite actually
now we're suing finally a a an
inflection point where software
engineers are trying to become
competitive with bankers and consultants
and and and other types of people in
terms of income and I mean what he
thinks allowing for that despite the
globalization phenomenon well you know
the way I always like to explain it is
that there isn't something called a lump
of Labor right we've got it and oh
you're gonna get it bring them back
that's not how it works okay so the best
way I could exploit least explain it
when I talk about the world is flat is
guess what not everything that needs to
be invented has been invented right and
the example I always give is your
daughter goes off to college my daughter
goes off to college and your kid goes
off to come back after first semester
and you say yeah so honey um what do you
think I'm majoring what do you think
you're gonna do she says dad I want to
be a search engine optimizer when I grew
up say what I sent you to college you
couldn't be an ophthalmologist or an
accountant what the hell is a search
engine
of course so here's an industry that
came from zero to multi-billion dollars
how do we optimize my website so if
Sol's in the tennis shoe business and
Tom's in the tennis shoe business when I
put tennis shoes into Google
Tom's tennis shoes comes up before
solves tennis shoes
it is now a multi-billion dollar
industry that's a mash-up by the way
between math and Madison Avenue's yeah
so it brings together advertising people
with with mathematicians whole new field
for people with software or math degrees
never existed before I and so Khan
Academy the software around distributed
online courses didn't exist ten years
ago you know and so all these things
keep getting invented but there's one
constant it seems to me sell and that's
every good job is either going out up or
down faster than ever that is it every
good job either requires more education
to do or it can be done by more people
computers or software yeah or it's being
outsourced to the past yeah faster
so every job is going in all three
directions or maybe not more education
in the formal sense if you know exactly
more competence competence very good
exactly one thing we know about search
engine optimizer you needed to know more
than you did you know to be a computer
repair person you know and so but but
what I think is exciting about this
moment and again this all be I would
argue enabled by the hyper connected
platform is that once it becomes a
competency game I can acquire those
competencies in any way and that's what
people don't appreciate about
globalization either I always say
globalization giveth and globalization
taketh globalization just made the
qualifications for this job higher and
it just brought you Khan Academy where
my daughter who was applying you know
for graduate school can go to to get
prepped for her GREs for free what she
did she did told me exactly hope she got
her money's worth she did money she got
in visited here doing so so it's not
it's doing boast at the same time and if
you miss that if you think it's all bad
or all good you don't get it and this
arts or the debate around globalization
to be that oh my god it's terrible it's
gonna kill us it's gonna overwhelm us or
it's wonderful it's great no it's
disruptive it's creative destruction on
steroids but the opportunities it's
unleashing for all different kinds of
people and so that my sort of overall
summary of it is that we're going from a
we're moving into a 401k world where
everyone will have to pass the bar exam
and no one will be able to escape the
most email list so versus the pension
world exactly so basically you were
going from a world of defined benefits
yes the tension world that's to defined
contributions for 30 years I work for
the New York Times I hated to find
benefit every year really it didn't
matter you know it was obviously tied to
my performance in general but basically
I got a define benefit from the New York
time yeah now I get a defined
contribution they'll give me X amount of
money and I have to take responsibility
for investing it wisely yeah so I think
that's happening to the whole labor
market we're going from a world of
defined benefits where you kind of be
protected by walls you go to college
you're fine you're fine job exactly get
that 4-year degree is it proxy exact for
a key and the door of a job that's right
okay no now it's we're in a world of
defined contributions the great thing
for all the people on Khan Academy is
there's no ceiling anymore it ain't
gonna matter in all my peers whether you
went to Stanford
you got those competencies on economy
the ceiling is gone though it's really
scary so are the floors and walls right
you know and so we're going from a
defined benefit world to a defined
contribution world that's what the
hyper-connectivity does second real
global meritocracy oh absolutely
anyone will be able to compete right
second it's a world where and B can be
what will enable that is we're moving to
a world where everyone will have to pass
the bar yeah that is in the old days we
said you're three years at Stanford Law
School oh well that may be 100 years we
said going to law school was a proxy for
knowing the law at some point the legal
profession said no no we're gonna you're
gonna go to law school but then you take
the bar that says you actually know what
you know that is coming I think to every
industry yeah you want to get a job
across three to Google I don't think you
just show up this I have a BA and
no they test you actually know what you
know you know because you're Tony Wagner
he says the world doesn't really care
what you know because the Google machine
knows everything okay the world only
pays off on what you can do with what
you know and we are now going to test
that right so my motto is everyone's
gonna have to pass the bar
third we all are going to have our own
most emailed machine so New York Times
go to York times.com any day you know
the most email columns changes every 15
minutes yeah
any journalist who says they don't look
at it is lying okay you always want to
see where your story your column
whatever did it go up the most human
nature I think what's coming is a most
email list is coming to a job near you
because with big data so we had a story
in the New York Times that Jamba Juice
has technology it's installed it's in
place where they can measure which
employees sell the most juice on Fifth
Avenue and 63rd Street at 80 degrees Wow
between 8:00 and 10:00 in the morning
and because they also divide their
workday in 15-minute increments the
employees who do that get the most
overtime Wow
they've got their most email lists now
if you go to school loop calm in your
world you can track your kids school
assignment what he she or she you know
whether she turned it in on time by the
way whether he or she is tardy you know
and you can the kids now have their most
email list so yeah these are almost
email lists that will connect to your
performance and display it in real time
and look it's all scary scary to me you
know this well I mean some people would
fear that okay this is gonna become very
automatic very you know okay these
things matter was how productive are you
at Jamba Juice but what about what about
the soft skills the the arts even and
and the arts impact on society as a
whole participation in democracy some of
these things that don't translate into
dollars at Jamba Juice so I think those
are again more important than ever
because what this world really enables
if you are self-motivated person and
you're living in a world of Khan Academy
if you are self-motivated kid in in Khan
Afghanistan and there's Khan Academy and
I've got an internet connection you can
suddenly you can go to the moon there's
no you met do you think are the walls
and ceilings
that person lived within and so that is
just really exciting if you are
self-motivated if you are not
self-motivated the walls and floors that
protected you are gone and so I think
the most important kind of leadership
for a company and leadership in the end
for teachers and for parents and for
coaches is education that inspires those
soft skills love of learning motivation
they are gonna matter hugely in a world
you more than ever saw because when
everything is out there now for you for
free if you access it you know and so
and that's that's sort of one side of
the soft skills but also it looks it's
great to know math and physics and
calculus and programming and you can't
be creative without them but poetry
music jazz sports collaboration all
those things that inspire people to take
the math and turn it into something of
beauty of something will make people's
lives more productive more healthy more
entertained more caring that all comes
from the other stuff so I think the
pendulum swung pretty far to this way in
terms of rigorous skill hard skills I
think we need to make sure it we come
back to the middle here and that we're
blending when we say blended model we
don't just mean teacher as a tutor more
and a coach and all the online stuff
taking care of the rest but blending
also all these other things if I read
between the lines we talked about these
new industries the difference between
the engineering jobs that are going to
India the ones that are the salaries are
increasing here is that it's it's
fundamentally right brained Oh totally
creative Madison Avenue absolutely
you're not really in you got into this
game by remediating y2k computer right
now what's cool to me about what's going
on in India a decade later is we're
seeing so when I wrote about the world
is flat in 2004 that was really based on
Indian solving our problems yeah y2k now
it's so exciting with this platform
they're using these incredibly cheap
tools of connectivity and collaboration
and the cloud to solve their problems so
if you look at
what innovators in Mexico India are
doing it's an explosion of innovation
we've got a mil a billion more brains
that potentially can be applied against
the biggest problems of humanity and if
that doesn't float your boat then
there's something wrong with you now at
the same time I understand the challenge
and we should get them to figure out how
we can solve the outsourcing problem
well it's it's it's uh they might do
that is don't put and I understand for a
lot of people are scary if you're a 50
year old guy or gal in a declining
industry and somebody comes to no
problem you can yo you can thrive just
go to Khan Academy yeah and take their
lessons a huge sympathy for that but
that's just so out of there they've been
protected by a wall and a floor they
didn't do this you know um you can use
all my tax dollars you want to help
those people and make a transition yeah
what we shouldn't do is though is block
the change yeah you know if horses could
vote there never would have been cars
all right it's always important to
remember that and so if you if you try
to stand in the way of the change I
would be a fun party game if horses
could code what would their blood what
else what would not what would there be
and what would there today I love the
way your mind is oh it's up but it's
because then you won't have the
resources to take care of people but I
have a huge sympathy for people caught
in that transition and no one should
ever mistake I get very excited talking
about things I discovered disconnections
I make but do not mistake my excitement
for just I love the puzzle you know I
mean wow that explains this and this
explains that and people should know
that that this is happening but don't
don't confuse it for unsympathetic
about all of this that I see the upside
in the downside but it leaves me net
worried in many ways Wow I'm gonna ask
you one last question where are you
going next you you hinted on it a little
bit and I found that fascinating because
you're doing two documentaries almost at
the same time well it's one day it's the
same documentary it's called climate
change in the Arab Spring it's for the
armed
Showtime Channel it's part of a six-part
climate series are gonna run next year
burn a Yemen
Sunday to look at Yemen the first
country the world that will probably run
out of water um you can go around sauna
you see water trucks all over the place
unfortunately the countries there's a
big addiction to cut this to qat it's a
drug I mean it's a plant that is a mild
narcotic but it consumes a lot of water
and somebody told me they were on a high
level
you know presidential visit or the
reasons the president of their country
the Secretary of State of their country
and they went with the president um and
somewhere in the pilot of the helicopter
was chewing God yes kind of leave me a
little worried get on American Airlines
yeah their pilot pilot cot on the boy
yeah but and then we're going to Syria
because people don't realize Syria had a
10-year drought yeah worst drought in in
their history Ron recorded history as
the lead-up to this a million farmers
and grazers had to leave the countryside
moved to the cities put huge pressure on
the infrastructure and it didn't cause
the revolution there but it was one of
the stresses that really helped
contribute to it and we're going to
Egypt because in 2010 in December 2010
there was a huge spike in global wheat
prices because there was a drought in
Australia there's a drought in Russia
and there was a drought in China or
flood what male uh D in Australia
drought in China drought in Russia and
as a result global wheat prices spiked
in December 2010 the exact same time of
the revolution
Arab Spring yeah exactly Tunisia and
Egypt then world food prices hit a
record high the month of the Tunisian
revolution Wow
and remember the guy who started the
revolution in Tunisia was a fruit seller
well he was a vegetable seller excuse me
and so these didn't cause the Arab
Spring but they were huge stresses on
the seller ated catalog and it shows you
that you know why you should take
climate change very seriously
Wow well on that note fairly epic note
yeah positive but this has been an acute
honor I think for all of us at the trade
fun for me thank you so much for coming
real treats I'll thank you very much
really appreciate it thank you
[Applause]